foreign
a few years ago the author Ross douthit
wrote a book called The decadent society
and in the book he argues that um we're
not headed for any kind of catastrophic
civilizational collapse but either we on
are on our way to and in fact already in
a period of stasis of cultural paralysis
what he calls decadence a decadent
Society is one that shreds water that
goes nowhere in particular and kind of
drifts along to various dead ends one of
the Hallmarks of the decadence Society
is that it has no new ideas instead it
simply repeats itself or repeats itself
and repeats old ideas over and over
again constantly recycled and remade
movies and lifeless movie franchises
that never end are the perfect example
of this kind of thing another is the
endless invention of new sexualities and
genders which are all just different
versions of being gay a slightly less
noticeable but for me even more annoying
example is this insistence
on taking normal things and making them
into trends
every week there's another Trend to
taking social media and gen Z by storm
but when you investigate you discover
that this is something people have
always been doing it's just that they
never felt the need to make it into a
hashtag
um I've just been made aware of a
particularly egregious variation on this
theme for example this is a a new trend
that's been written about in many media
Publications it's called girl dinner and
here's the National Geographic report
because this is the kind of thing the
National Geographic now concerns itself
with long honor the days when you you
know
go to National Geographic to learn about
a lost tribe and it's a South American
jungle somewhere now you learn about the
eating habits of 23 year old women on
tick tock so here's what they say quote
picture this you're home alone and it's
nearing dinner time you grab a box of
crackers from the cabinets some olives
baby carrots and leftover falafel from
the fridge you can take your Masterpiece
to the table but why bother there's
something satisfyingly deviant about
eating it right off the kitchen counter
with your fingers all told the meal
takes five minutes one plate no utensils
you my friend have just made yourself a
girl dinner what once may have been a
sheepish solitary tradition has recently
attained viral internet status thanks to
Olivia Marr a TV show Runners assistant
who first christed the phenomenon and
Tick Tock posted in May you sort of
Choose Your Own Adventure tasting
platter girl dinner can include anything
and often includes everything from
applesauce and salami to Cheetos and
guacamole the trend that sends a mass
nearly 1 billion views on Tick Tock
where users have started sharing their
own Smorgasbord creations and absurdist
parodies social media hyper side might
the girl dinner girls and their fellow
partakers be onto something food experts
weigh in on the potential merits and
pitfalls of this low effort snack
forward meal and what it reveals about
relationship to food and each other
now first of all this is not an
Innovative Trend you haven't discovered
anything new you're just you're eating
okay you're consuming food that's what
it's called Uh people have been doing
that for as long as people have existed
and second to the extent that there is a
particular method or approach here it's
not fair to call it girl dinner in fact
I would go so far as to label this a
form of cultural appropriation single
men have been doing this forever maybe
not with falafels and olives but the
general strategy is very familiar when I
was a single man I don't think I ate a
dinner on a plate with an entree and a
side dish even one time if I was hungry
I went to my kitchen opened up the
fridge I stood facing the fridge with
the door still open and I ate whatever
random items happen to have I have I
happen to have in there which wasn't
much never heat anything up you know I
didn't put it on a plate and sit by
myself at the dining room table
mostly because I didn't have a dining
room table or plates
or a dining room
or really any furniture at all except
for a couch and a mattress and box
spring with no bed frame the point is
that the girl dinner Trend directly
steals from ancient Bachelor tradition
our culture is not your Tick Tock Trend
you Damned plagiarous
when it comes to doing something that
people have been doing forever and
pretending that you invented a hot new
trend nowhere is this more common than
in the workplace we've discussed several
times in the past these alleged new
workplace trends that are not new at all
and are almost always just a version of
being lazy quiet quitting is one we've
discussed uh there have been others in
that same vein and now Business Insider
has compiled for whatever reason the
whole list so we now have all of the
workplace Trends quote unquote that gen
Z has invented this year and one handy
list headline from Lazy Girl jobs to
loud quitting here are the biggest
workplace buzzwords of 2023 and what
they mean the article begins Fed Up
employees are starting new workplace
trends that push back on exploitative
employers enter Lazy Girl jobs allowed
quitting and bare minimum Mondays check
out these and other big workplace
buzzwords of 2023 and what experts have
to say about them
now a few of these buzzwords actually
have the effect of taking a healthy and
productive thing and making it sound
worse than it really is so here's one
rage applying Business Insider says rage
applying is the practice of mass
applying to jobs fueled by feelings of
unhappiness at work
and it seems it has the potential to pay
off after being passed over for a
promotion promotion Jordan Smith a 28
year old uh working in the music
industry in La rage applied for five
jobs and landed a better paying role
within a week however rage applying
might not be the best approach for
everyone career coach Kelsey watt
advises against conducting a job search
from an emotional place of fear
resentment or burnout
okay
well this is not rage applying this is
just applying this is the standard
application process if you're looking
for a new job especially if you're
looking for an entry-level job it's a
good idea to fill out multiple
applications or send in multiple resumes
applying for five jobs is not anything
excessive or impressive it's what you do
if you're serious about finding a job
and you probably don't want to be in a
state of Rage while you're filling out
the application but I don't think that's
happening anyway
I'm not even sure what that would look
like like a guy sitting at his computer
faces red frothing at the mouth
trembling with rage while filling out
his employment history and contact
information it just it just seems
somewhat incongruent you can't maintain
actual rage while filling out a form
it's more of a it's more of a feeling of
numbness and quiet despair if anything
now before giving our dog rough grains
he was so sad and lazy and now he's
still lazy like all dogs are he doesn't
participate at all doesn't contribute
anything to the family but he actually
enjoys his squeaky toys playing Fetch
with his frisbee our pups days are
filled with laughter exercise and
endless fun
as I always say naturopathic Dr Dennis
black the founder of rough greens is
focused on improving the health of every
dog in America little did I know before
I got rough greens dog food is dead food
everyone knows that nutrition isn't
Brown it's green well rough grains boost
your dog's food back to life rough
grains is a supplement contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
and mega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy a new dog
you just uh you don't need to buy a new
dog or new dog food you just sprinkle
rough grains on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
grains it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are a weed and that
goes for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident rough grains will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so your dog can try at a free jumpstart
trial back could be at your door in just
a few business days go to
roughgreens.com Matt or call 844 rough
700. it's ruffgreens.com or 844 rough
700 today
but now we get to the fancy workplace
buzzwords that all describe the same
kind of laziness and incompetence Now
read it from the article it says quote
as major tech companies continue laying
off significant numbers of workers
another workplace trend has emerged
resenteeism it describes the act of
staying in an unsatisfying job due to a
perceived lack of options even as
resentment grows after resenteeism came
the synonymous loud quitters and grumpy
stairs
gallup's 2023 state of the global
workplace report found that roughly one
in five workers are loud quitting at
their jobs which means just that they're
actively disengaged at work as opposed
to quietkitters quitters who are simply
not engaged wait what
so on one hand you are disengaged on the
other hand you are not engaged wow
that's quite a distinction
now just as a quick note that goes
without saying if you have ever referred
to yourself as a grumpy stayer
you should not only be fired from your
job but you should also be deported to
Venus
but there's a lot more in this vein
there's also bare minimum Monday which
we're told is a way to ease into work at
the start of the week tick tocker
Marissa Joe popularized the term which
describes a way to resist the Sunday
scaries and the pressure many people
feel to hit the ground running full
speed when they return to work again on
Monday quote the second I got rid of the
pressure and allowed myself to have
whatever kind of day unfolded I was able
to do stuff she said uh in a in a video
documenting one of her bare minimum
Mondays Joe goes through activities like
journaling or skincare routine making
progress on a creative project before
beginning work which she notes doesn't
start until noon on bare minimum Mondays
yes you know it's important to ward off
the Sunday scaries by having a bare
minimum Monday so you don't become a
grumpy stayer who is quiet quitting
and if you've not already overdosed and
died of cringe just from hearing that
sentence don't forget about chaotic
working Business Insider explains
chaotic working aka malicious compliance
involves employees using their position
at work to help customers or clients at
the employer's expense though it often
entails breaking some rules workers may
do it without fear of repercussion
because they're simply fed up with their
job their employer or their General
State of work anti-work sentiments have
helped the trend grow
now that last sentence is really the key
here putting aside how unfathomably
cringy all this is and how it's all just
trying to make Trends out of Simply
being a garden variety loser with no
work ethic the real point is that it
grows from as Business Insider says
anti-work sentiment
now to a certain extent everybody has
experienced anti-work sentiment everyone
who you know everyone who Among Us has
not had the alarm go off in the middle
in the morning and thought to themselves
damn I don't feel like going to work
today
we will have and everyone has lapsed
into laziness some more often than
others so that isn't new
but these days thanks in part to the
trend defying of everyday of everyday
life if I can coin my own dumb and
clunky term
being lazy and anti-work is now
presented as a legitimate lifestyle
choice
okay it's one thing to have lazy moments
that that's everyone does
it's another to declare your laziness
proudly to participate in laziness like
it's a valid life strategy
that's where we are now especially with
the younger Generations
I mean you can feel anti-work sometimes
everyone does
but to make that into your motto to
March under that Banner
is to embrace failure and misery and
mediocrity
and this is the part that gets me
because look
if you want to be mediocre unimpressive
unproductive achieve nothing of value
with your life that's your choice it's a
bad choice but it's yours to make
the problem though is that the people
who openly admit that they do the bare
minimum and that they walk around at
work with open resentment and hostility
to their own employer
they put in no effort Etc
these people will still complain in fact
they will complain the loudest
about their financial hardships and
their lacks lack of opportunities and so
on
you know if you want to work little and
and you want to have little and you want
to live a humble life with without much
luxury or Comfort if you want to go you
know live in a one-bedroom Cottage in
the woods somewhere with no streaming
services or designer clothes or anything
else
if you want to embrace a very modest
life so that you can devote more of your
time to your hobbies or your art or
simply to contemplating the mysteries of
the universe that I can more than
respect that's a respectable choice
if you want to leave quote hustle
culture behind and Go full monastic or
close to it great that is an absolutely
respectable approach to life and you can
find plenty of joy and fulfillment
living that way
but that is not what most of the quiet
quitters and bear minimum Monday
participants are doing not even close
because they still want to live a fully
Modern Life with all the trappings all
the luxuries all the streaming services
all the nice clothes and gadgets
but without putting in any of the effort
to obtain and maintain that kind of
Lifestyle so they are the worst of all
worlds that's the point it's
materialistic and lazy okay it's one
thing to choose one of those so if
you've got if you have to be like at
least choose one
okay if you want to be lazy but not
materialistic
that's that's something oh yeah they're
lazy but they're not materialistic at
all they don't care about you know they
don't they don't need to own anything
and they don't care about it
or you could be materialistic but
ambitious and people could say about you
yeah it's real materialistic but man
he's ambitious he's a real go-getter
that's something I mean you could work
with that and you could be a successful
person in your own way that way you can
be happy too that way
the problem is that that modern people
many modern people want both of those
vices
you can't have both of them you gotta
choose one you can't be materialistic
and lazy
because that's where it all breaks down
that's a recipe for being eternally
frustrated and unfulfilled
and that is the fate of so many people
in our culture today
which is why all the people
participating in these trends that are
not really trends
are today canceled thanks for checking
out this video if you'd like to listen
to my full podcast on the go you can
check out the Matt wall show on Apple
podcast Spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts